what do you think happens from this
point do you is there
any save possible here because on the
way out
they give to get him out he's such a
shark
he gets paid a huge payment to leave
while everybody else gets but they
didn't pay him everything right there
there was a little claw back
yep and are they in a lawsuit over that
what's the latest on that
yeah there's been a couple of clawbacks
that we just learned this week um
i mean roughly speaking adam got a got a
billion dollar payout to leave the
company and and
there were various parts of that some
were paying back loans that he had taken
out um
some of it was a consulting fee uh 185
million dollar consulting fee
to advise the business and partly to
make sure he didn't go start
a competitor um and then there was a
secondary offer that that he was they
were going to buy
a chunk of his stock along with along
with other shareholders to
roughly um uh be about it be about a
billion dollars
uh that tender offer is stuck in a
lawsuit softbank has said that that
wework um
has sort of reneged on some terms of the
deal
there are they have cited um some uh
investigations
being conducted by several state
attorneys general
uh that we don't know too much about but
but south bank has cited this to sort of
hold up that end of the deal and then
um just this week marcelo claret who
is one of massa's deputies at softbank
and came in as the chairman of wework
after
adam was pushed out uh says that they
have not paid adam
all of that consulting fee so uh he he's
fine um he he did just invest uh 30
million dollars into
a a residential living company last week
so he has money to throw around um but
he doesn't quite have
the billion dollars yet yeah see it's
very interesting i thought his other
idea that was very prescient and
a huge winner was we live that was
another great idea
it's it's a good i'm skeptical of it and
i'm okay let's hash it out yeah
in new york um where uh
me and my cohort of people in their 30s
and i i think
most people what we want is is the
largest
apartment we can possibly afford and
what what adam
was offering was the smallest apartment
you could possibly find but
i'm gonna give you some common space to
to sort of hang out with with people
um that uh it's it's a nice idea it's
sort of
based in in kind of the kibbutz that
that adam grew up in in in some ways but
and and it might be nice if humans were
more open to
spending lots of time with uh the people
other people who live in their apartment
building but the ra
the reality at least in most cities is
that we all kind of
we all want our own spaces um for better
awareness and maybe
even especially more now yeah the
pandemic does change that i thought
when i was in my 20s in manhattan when i
was sleeping in my office at sony
and i would literally because i had an
apartment way out in brooklyn i would
sleep under my desk
two or three nights a week in a sleeping
bag that i had in my file cabinet
in my tiny little closet office and then
i would shower in the gym and so if i
went out at night i just tell people i'm
going to the server room to reboot some
computers and i just sleep under my desk
and they just kind of like you might
have liked that we live yeah and i
thought we live was like pretty good for
the 20s crowd
but then again back then you didn't want
to be in brooklyn now you do want to be
in brooklyn back then true
you wanted to be in manhattan at all
costs so being able to stay in manhattan
overnight was like
a huge goal